[MUSIC PLAYING]
DANNY HERMES: Hey, everybody.
Welcome back to Google
App Engine, Google
Developers Live this week.
We were here, both me
and Dan, last week.
For those who weren't here,
I'm Danny Hermes.
I work on App Engine.
And we're here specifically
today--
DAN HOLEVOET: To talk about
Google Cloud Endpoints.
So if you haven't heard about
Endpoints before, it's--
well, App Engine, in general,
is a really great place to
build backends for your
mobile applications.
And Endpoints, which is a
feature we recently released
as part of the 175 SDK, allows
it even more easily make App
Engine a backend for your
mobile applications.
And we allow you to do this by
allowing you to annotate code
that you have within your
application to easily expose
APIs that you consume from
within an Android, iOS, or
JavaScript applications.
So last week, we started
building a task management
application.
And Danny, why don't you tell
us a little bit more about
that app and how we can
improve upon it?
DANNY HERMES: Yes.
So I mentioned a few times while
we were building it last
week that there were things
that could be done easier.
And Dan actually just said,
when he was talking about
Endpoints and its release, that
we were trying to make it
more easy to build APIs
in App Engine.
Well, today, I want to talk to
you about this library called
Endpoints Proto Datastore, which
is going to take more
easy and make it more easy.
So I'm going to start
off with the code
that we had last week.
I'm actually here on the
Downloads page where there's a
zip of the library.
I'm not going to download
it yet.
But first I'm going to start
off and review the
application, what it did, and
then that way when we go
through an upgrade, it'll
be a bit easier.
This is the exact same source
as I left with last week,
except I switched the order of
these first two imports.
Dan didn't stop me.
They were out of alphabetical
order.
That's not adhering to the
Python style guide.
We do some other things at
Google that are a bit
different than the Python
style guide.
But definitely alphabetical
order is universal bad.
Anyhow--
DAN HOLEVOET: It was
live coding.
DANNY HERMES: It was
DAN HOLEVOET: It's
probably OK.
DANNY HERMES: Sure.
Only 100%.
We only have room for 100%.
Anyway, so we have
a few imports.
So Endpoints, obviously, is
a dependency, and then ndb
because we were persisting data,
and then we had some
ProtoRPC imports.
For those who haven't watched
the video yet or are curious,
ProtoRPC is a way for us to have
native Python objects,
which can actually be turned
into protocol buffers, which
is actually what Endpoints uses
from within App Engine to
talk to the rest of Google's
API infrastructure.
And I definitely go on and on,
lots of wind coming out of
this wind bag, a bit
more last week.
So if you want to hear more
about it, go watch the video.
So I have imports for actually
making message classes, a
specialized module called
message_types, and then a
module called remote, which we
actually used to define the
service object for the API.
Then from there, we define
some things to
represent our data.
So this first thing-- task
that we see here--
is a ProtoRPC message
to represent tasks
for our task list.
And right next to it is the
corresponding ndb model to
hold the data persistently
in the data store for our
application.
And then finally, since we
wanted people to actually find
out how many tasks they had,
we defined a task list
ProtoRPC model, which had a
single field, which was a
repeated field for messages so
we could just send back all
the tasks--
excuse me, for task messages.
So we could send back all the
tasks that we had inserted up
to that point.
Then from there, we actually
created a task API, which is,
as I mentioned, a subclass
of remote.Service.
And this actually won't change
from this sample to the sample
which I'm going to
write today.
And we specify some
API metadata.
And then we had two methods,
insert_task and list_tasks.
And on each of these, in the
endpoints.method decorator, we
also supply some metadata, which
includes the ProtoRPC
classes needed to actually--
to serialize our data from
Google's API infrastructure to
our application and then
on the way out.
And then finally, we create an
actual application, which is a
WSGI application, which our
app.yaml routes to using
endpoints.api_server.
We just give it a list of all
our APIs and just had one API.
So great.
That was last week.
Now, this week.
I'm going to first download a
zip, which just contains the
library we're going to use.
I anticipate this will
be very quick.
So get ready.
After we upgrade the
application, we're going to do
some more things than
we did last week.
Time pending.
So I'm here if you-- that
is not the right link.
I'm here on the Downloads
page within the
endpoints-proto-datastore
project
on Google code hosting.
And if you click the
endpoints_proto_datastore.zip
link, you'll be taken to
the Download page.
Now, we see there's two
downloads already.
Well, that was actually me.
So get out there and
download it.
But I'm going to click
this link.
I'm going to copy the link, and
I'm just going to copy it
into my directory using wget.
OK, so we've download it.
And it's there.
So now I'm going to unzip it.
And I've extracted everything
I need.
OK, so now I can go ahead
and get to work.
So I'm going to open this
main.py backup.
Actually, before I do that, I
just want to prove to everyone
that app still works.
Let's do that, and maybe
add one task.
So I came here to my Google App
Engine Launcher, and then
I'm going to go into
Chrome for
localhost8080/_ah/api/explore.
And I'm going to make calls from
the Google APIs Explorer.
Again, we talked about
this last week.
And we even had a custom
version, vGDL, for our
application.
If people are interested in
using the APIs Explorer,
please add to our already
1,400 plus views on last
week's video.
OK, we have the API.
We have the two methods
we expect.
And let's see.
Name.
Go to sleep.
And the owner, Danny.
Sweet.
OK, it works.
And I'll just double check
the list also works.
OK, great.
So now I'm going to upgrade
the application.
So starting with
our endpoints--
or excuse me, our imports.
I had a little Freudian
slip there.
There's a few that we
can throw away.
And this is what
makes me happy.
So we have here task and task
model side by side.
And we have to define them even
though it's the exact
same thing.
StringField, StringProperty
required=True is identical
from one to the other.
So we wanted to make something
sort of magical.
We actually were calling it
magic mode amongst ourselves
for a while.
That would allow you to still
be able to speak ProtoRPCs,
still be able to speak protocol
buffers, but to also
be able to persist your data.
So that's where Endpoints Proto
Datastore comes in.
So I actually get to throw away
messages and message types.
I don't need either of those.
I'm still going to keep
endpoints because it helps me
assign metadata to methods
and the API.
And I'm still going to keep ndb
because in our library, we
actually took advantage
of the properties that
already exist for ndb.
Now I'm going to add
another import.
This library I just added,
endpoints_proto_datastore.
And it has a sub-package
called ndb.
And from within there, I'm going
to import a model called
EndpointsModel.
And this is really just a
subclass of ndb.model that is
more easy, like I said.
We haven't implemented it, but
we're certainly open for
others to implement different
persistence layers than ndb.
For example, if people
want to use db--
don't know why you would
because ndb is better.
But if people do, the
utilities are there.
The shared utilities are there
for you to be able to
implement Endpoints Proto
Datastore.db in the same
fashion ndb is.
And if people are using Cloud
SQL or people are using Google
Cloud Storage, people are using
Google Drive even, the
utilities are there for you to
extend this to some other
persistence layer, but we
chose handy-dandy ndb.
Because for us, for using
the Datastore,
it's certainly easiest.
So great, I'm just going to
throw away this first task.
I don't need it.
And in TaskModel, I can actually
just get rid of
ndb.model and use
Endpoints.Model.
It really is this simple.
If people have existing
applications and they want to
turn them into an API, it's
really this simple to get the
persistence right.
Now, just for me, because I have
very specific tastes, I'd
rather just call it Task instead
of TaskModel since we
no longer have this
name collision.
So I'm also going to do that.
There's a bit more code
to strip out.
In addition, I'd no longer
need the TaskList.
Actually, making lists or
collections out of items from
within this TaskModel is
supported out of the box by
Endpoints Proto Datastore.
Great.
So we've gone from three
models to one.
That's awesome, right?
DAN HOLEVOET: Sounds
good to me.
DANNY HERMES: So now, I don't
have to actually change the
metadata associated with
the application.
We have the name tags, version
vGDL, and a human readable
description.
Don't have to change the
subclass it inherits from, but
I am going to be changing
how we're
actually using our method.
So rather than using the
Endpoints.method decorator and
having to specify the request
and response ProtoRPC type of
the request, I can
actually just use
this model I've defined.
And it has a class method which
acts as a decorator.
So instead of endpoints.method,
I can just
use task.method.
And I can completely get rid of
these old ProtoRPC classes
which no longer exist anyhow.
And the rest of the metadata
can still be kept around.
I'm also going to get rid
of http_method='POST'.
I mentioned last week that it
was the default, and I didn't
actually need it.
It's the same here.
It's the default, so I'm
not going to throw
it in for no reason.
And the great things about using
task.method instead of
endpoints.method is?
DAN HOLEVOET: Fewer
lines of code.
DANNY HERMES: Fewer
So what we have here--
I was previously taking the
actual task ProtoRPC object
and first casting it into an ndb
object before putting it
into the Datastore.
When you wrap your API method
with task.method, or whatever
your endpoints model is .method,
you actually get an
entity of that model rather than
some ProtoRPC object that
you have to convert, and then
convert back and forth.
So instead of request, we
actually have a task in our
hands immediately.
And so instead of converting it
to something else, we can
say, hey, put that task
in the Datastore.
Tasks love to be in
the Datastore.
And instead of having
to cast it back
into a ProtoRPC request--
again, task.method--
the decorator will do
all that for us.
So we just give it an entity and
it does whatever it needs
to do with that entity
on the way out.
So it's really that simple to
convert our insert method.
Now, instead of converting the
list method, I'm just going to
show you guys that it works
first and comment out this
other code.
If I didn't comment it out, we
would have some issues with
name errors, things that don't
exist and it is trying to use.
So I'm commenting it out.
And let's head over
to our API.
So I'm going to refresh
this page.
We should see list disappear.
It did.
Wonderful.
DAN HOLEVOET: High five.
DANNY HERMES: No errors.
I like when I'm live
coding that--
to have some errors.
But unfortunately, since we've
taken more easy and made it
more easy, it's almost
impossible to have errors.
DAN HOLEVOET: We have
to run it first.
DANNY HERMES: We
have to run it.
Thank you.
Dan is calling me out
on my hubris.
We do have to run it.
OK, so we're in this method.
It's completely different.
We have no more from ProtoRPC
import messages.
Yet we still see the same
strongly typed things from our
discovery document that
we saw before.
OK, great.
So I'll add something,
wake up.
Danny should also wake up.
Now, this is where time stamps
would come in handy.
DAN HOLEVOET: Yeah, it would.
DANNY HERMES: Honestly, it's
really easy to do with
Endpoints Proto Datastore, but I
don't know if we're going to
be doing it today.
So we'll make Danny
the owner again.
Let's see if it works.
Let's just see if it works.
DAN HOLEVOET: Oh, it worked.
DANNY HERMES: Oh, it worked.
Wonderful.
I was a little nervous there.
Great.
So now let's actually
convert list tasks.
Now, there's actually a reason
I wanted to do these
separately.
Because rather than having one
decorator for all methods,
endpoints.method, we realized
that having collections and
paging through things and
actually getting queries was a
special kind of API request.
So Endpoints Proto Datastore on
Endpoints models provides a
special class method called
query_method.
So rather than just being
called task.method, it's
called task.query_method.
And it's made just
for queries.
So again, as with insert task, I
no longer need the types for
the way in and the way out.
I can just forget about it.
And the rest of the metadata
completely accepted by this
method, and even the http_method
get, while, it's a
query, get is what you're
doing when it's a query.
If you try to use an http_method
other than get,
query method will tell you, no,
I'm not going to do any
work for you because that's
all it's supposed to do.
It's a query.
So we can get rid
of that as well.
And instead of having an unused
request, we actually
have an ndb query object,
which we can use.
And luckily, we don't actually
have to do anything with it.
But if we have the requisite
time, we're actually going to
add some auth to this.
And we'll be doing queries
based on that.
But we're certainly
not there yet.
So this query method takes
all of this work.
So I had to use the task
model, create a query.
Then for each of those tasks, I
had to take them from an ndb
entity, cast them into
a ProtoRPC entity.
And then after that, I had to
take this list of ProtoRPC
entities and pack it into a
task list ProtoRPC entity.
Instead, just return query.
And as Dan said so meekly
last time--
DAN HOLEVOET: Fewer
lines of code.
DANNY HERMES: Less code.
Fewer lines of code.
Playing code golf here.
Great.
So we should be done and ready
to extend the app, but let's
make sure it actually works.
So we'll head back
to the API page.
We'll refresh, see if
we get both methods.
All right, no errors.
It loaded.
First I'll try out lists
since we assume we
didn't break insert.
OK.
DAN HOLEVOET: Interesting.
DANNY HERMES: So this
is somewhat--
I expected to get back Danny
wake up and Danny go to sleep.
However, I'm realizing
now if we--
where is it?
If we go to the Admin page for
our application, they were
different kinds.
DAN HOLEVOET: Yes, they were.
DANNY HERMES: So this is
querying for the kind task,
which is what I renamed the
model to and which is the name
of the Endpoints model
we just defined.
And so I do see wake
up Danny in task.
That is probably way too small
to see on the internet.
I can see wake up
Danny in task.
And in task model, we
see that old one.
So go to sleep Danny didn't
make it, but that's OK.
DAN HOLEVOET: It's not
technically a bug.
DANNY HERMES: It's not a bug.
It's not a bug.
It's a bug in my expectations.
Get some better expectations,
man.
So essentially, before we do
some new things, an overview
here is your persistence layer
and your abstraction layer to
actually convert your entities
into something that Google's
API infrastructure can
understand are exactly the
same with Endpoints
Proto Datastore.
So do you have anything you want
to add before I move on?
DAN HOLEVOET: No.
I think the big point here
is fewer lines of code.
Actually, can you compare the
number of lines in your new
example with the old one?
DANNY HERMES: Sure.
If I have them.
Let's see.
What do I want to do this?
DAN HOLEVOET: You had
a real demo folder.
Was it in there?
DANNY HERMES: I know.
So 50 lines is what it is.
That's what that means.
30.
29.
There we go, that's the
number we care about.
And then, in case I screwed
this up, I had a demo_real
folder and it had last
week's code.
That had 45 lines of code.
So we've lost a third
of our code.
And if you take away the
boilerplate, we're talking 50%
or more of the code that we've
actually cut away.
DAN HOLEVOET: Nice.
DANNY HERMES: And the big
thing is we had three
relatively simple models, and
we condensed them into one.
Well, you can imagine if you
took that up and had some
pretty complex models how much
code that would compress.
It'd be a lot more than three
lines gone for this and three
lines gone for that.
So before I move on and do auth,
I want to show you some
of the paging capabilities
automatically enabled out of
the box by query_method.
So the analogy here to actually
specifying a ProtoRPC
message definition for your
request and your response is
actually having the fields
from your model
that you want to use.
So as we'll see in a bit when I
add auth, we would sometimes
want to have a field not
sent from the API,
but satisfy it locally.
And sometimes otherwise.
So we actually, out of the box,
have some helper fields
for queries.
We have a limit to the
amount of results
we want to get back.
We have a page token if we want
to pick up in the middle
of a query.
If you get the first two and you
want to get the next two,
you can actually use a
page token from that.
Let me see, what--
DAN HOLEVOET: Sorting.
DANNY HERMES: We do
have sorting.
We're not going to use
this out of the box.
But essentially, we could use
a query field either of name
or owner, and it would
automatically sort by them.
Actually, it's filtering.
Sorting isn't right
out of the box.
But let's do the paging, which
is what I wanted to do.
So for our query fields, we're
just going to specify a limit
and a page token.
I'm going to consult the
documentation for Endpoints
Proto Datastore just to
refresh my memory.
So I don't have a link that's
actually going to
show up in the video.
But if you go to
endpoints-proto-
datastore.appspot.com, we have
nine samples there that are
decently annotated.
And all of the source code
actually lives with the source
for the library itself.
DAN HOLEVOET: It's pretty
snazzy looking.
DANNY HERMES: It's decently
Dan actually helped me with
the CSS for this because--
DAN HOLEVOET: I was fishing
for comments here.
DANNY HERMES: No, I know.
I'm not saying you were.
He has the CSS Kung Fu,
and I have none of it.
And we were able to actually
figure out how to highlight
each of our code sections and do
some other cool things with
sections that actually
aren't on different
sides of the page.
OK, order.
I see.
You're right, you
can do order.
So if we were to provide
like order=name, it
would order by name.
But we're only really worried
about the limit and page token
part of query for now.
OK, great.
DAN HOLEVOET: Ordering by time
stamp would be really useful.
DANNY HERMES: Totally.
And we'll save that
for another day.
But it's certainly easy.
And these samples even briefly
delve into how
you might do that.
OK, great.
So before we can actually make
use of limit and page token,
we need more than one item.
So I'm going to insert
a couple.
I will assign all
of them to Dan.
Let's see, fewer
lines of code.
There we go.
There's a task.
What's something else
you want to do?
Drink some water.
DAN HOLEVOET: There we go.
DANNY HERMES: We'll have
some tasks for
our Mystery GDL Producer.
Write more often.
DAN HOLEVOET: How about
write unit tests?
DANNY HERMES: Who's that for?
Write unit tests.
DAN HOLEVOET: The
code janitor.
DANNY HERMES: Code janitor.
All right.
So we've got a fair
amount of tasks.
So this is good.
So here's our list of tasks.
They're in items, the same key
that we had last week.
This is by default what query
methods use within Endpoints
Proto Datastore.
It just so happened to be
the same attribute name
we used last week.
I kind of did it on purpose.
But this is a general term that
we see in all of Google's
querying APIs that's
used to mean this.
I need to reload this.
There we go.
So I don't know if people just
saw what happened there.
But when I reloaded my page,
I held Shift so it wouldn't
actually get from the cache.
So even though I had updated
the API, we didn't see this
limit and page token pieces up
on this page because the APIs
Explorer caches the discovery
document that it's using to
actually build these elements
in the DOM within this page,
within this nice, little
application.
So if you're having issues,
you updated your API and
you're not seeing it,
try to clear the
cache in your browser.
Or maybe just hold Shift
down when you refresh.
I believe this works in Firefox,
Safari, and some
other browsers as well.
DAN HOLEVOET: Chrome.
DANNY HERMES: I don't use them
on a day-to-day basis, so I
can't really tell you.
Sorry.
So the first thing I did, I
specified two as our limit.
So rather than getting
back all six items--
I believe it was six--
we see just two of them.
So Danny wake up and Dan
Holevoet fewer lines of code.
In addition to items,
we actually get a
next page token value.
And this next page token can be
used to get the next two or
the next one.
And so I can just throw
that in as page token
and execute a request.
And out of the box,
we have paging.
Dan, drink some water.
Mystery GDL Producer,
write more often.
All right, keep producing
for now.
We'll hold off on that one.
And it's really this
easy to just get
paging out of the box.
So now I want to do auth.
Before I do auth, briefly I want
to say our documentation
about auth handles
this pretty well.
We've got a link to it that
should be showing up anytime.
There are some different
concepts around allowed client
ID and audiences.
Audiences are really specific
to Android.
But allowed client IDs is
something where if you're via
the web or via the command
line or iOS, or somewhere
else, if you're actually minting
an OAuth2 token,
there's a specific client who is
standing between Google and
the user that's actually
facilitating this dance.
And this user has a client ID.
And so in order to know that
the token is valid for our
application, we have to know
which client IDs are allowed
to mint tokens on behalf of
our application's users.
So luckily, what you read in
this documentation we won't
actually have to apply it since
we're just using the
APIs Explorer.
Because if you don't specify any
white-listed client IDs,
which you can do in
endpoints.api or
endpoints.method decorators, or
in this case the endpoints
model.method decorators, if
you don't specify those
values, by default the client
ID corresponding to the APIs
Explorer will just work.
So again, for my memory, I'm
going to consult the
basic_with_auth sample doc.
I forget the keyword argument
we use-- user required.
There we go, such a simple
keyword argument.
So adding auth to
these methods--
not kidding you--
it is as easy as adding
user_required to the metadata
in the decorators.
Has anyone ever tried
OAuth before?
DAN HOLEVOET: I think that's
probably the easiest
implementation of an OAuth
feature I've ever seen.
DANNY HERMES: Yeah.
So this doesn't implement
client-side OAuth.
I'm not trying to say I've
done the whole thing.
But server-side OAuth?
Done.
user_required=True,
that's all.
So if I go back to my
application, wherever it
lives, and actually try to
execute a request, it says,
no, no, no, not happening.
If gives me the 401
status code.
And for those who aren't
familiar, for those who
haven't been banging their head
against the table or wall
trying to figure OAuth, 401
means you're not allowed,
you're unauthorized to
view this resource.
And as we see in the
error message, we
have an invalid token.
So what we're going to do, we're
actually just going to
authorize the request using
OAuth2 in the APIs Explorer.
Now, you can see our
documentation more for how you
do this in some other native
environments, but we really
just want to concentrate on the
server-side stuff for now.
So we need to actually
input our scope here.
So our scope--
this is one I hope
I remember--
https://www.goog
leapis.com/auth/userinfo.email.
Now, since App Engine thinks of
users in terms of emails,
we actually need the email scope
in order to actually
take an OAuth token and turn
it into an App Engine user.
So this is actually crucial.
You can use other scopes, but
for the 175 release-- maybe
you want to say a bit
more about this--
the email scope is really the
most relevant and sort of the
only relevant one.
DAN HOLEVOET: Right.
I mean, the key piece here is
that the user email address is
really critical to App Engine's
concept of a user and
the user object.
So to make things as clear as
possible, we suggest using the
userinfo.emailscope to
authorize the user.
DANNY HERMES: Yes.
And for those who were paying
attention, maybe Mystery GDL
Producer took it
off the screen.
I had to sign in because I am
in an incognito, or in an
empty Chrome profile.
But I signed in as one of my
aliases, Bossy Lobster.
So I'm allowing access
to the APIs Explorer.
It's really just asking me to
view my email address and know
who I am on Google.
So now I see this Off switch
turned to an On switch.
And now my requests have auth.
So I get back the same results
I expected, but I have to be
authenticated to do it.
DAN HOLEVOET: And you can see
the token in there in the
header to the left.
DANNY HERMES: Yes, we can
see the token for
this worthless account.
And we can actually
do things with it.
The token will only get you
the email, which is
dhermes@bossylobster.com.
So not quite the magic we're
hoping it could be.
OK, great.
So we're going to actually use
users and have queries
associated with the current
user so that the user
inserting something is also
associated with it.
So we can actually do
this by setting--
I'm cheating again,
just a little bit.
So instead of using owner as a
string, we're going to make
owner an ndb user property.
Is that the name of the class?
I think it is, right?
DAN HOLEVOET: I believe so.
DANNY HERMES: Yes.
OK.
So we will actually have owner
as an ndb user property.
And this is going to
be really fun.
And we're actually setting
the owner based
on the current user.
So now, Dan was mentioning
using fewer
fields or more fields.
Just like we use query_fields=
in the query_method, we're
going to use request_fields= in
the insert method to only
have the name of the task.
And the reason we only want
the name of the task is
because the owner comes
from the token.
That comes from the auth stuff,
and we don't want the
user specifying their own thing
with a different token.
We want tokens and users
matching up one to one.
So for our request fields,
we're only
going to accept a name.
Now, let's go do this
and actually check
it out in the Datastore.
I want to clear my Datastore,
so let me change the setting
to Clear Datastore on Launch.
So I went to the App
Engine Launcher.
I stopped the application that
was running, went to the Info
for the application, and
then clicked Clear
Datastore on Launch.
So when I come back, I'm going
to have an empty Datastore.
So now, when I actually
go to Insert an API--
maybe there's an issue.
That would be fun.
Oh, I know what I did.
So what did I do?
For those astute in Python, I
tried to make a tuple with one
element and didn't have
a comma at the end.
So Python thinks it's a string,
because it is a string.
That's what Python's
syntax says.
And everyone barfed because
we needed a tuple.
We needed something we
could iterate over
that wasn't a string.
OK, great.
So my bad.
Bug gone.
There we go.
So we got the tasks API.
We commented out list,
so we're just
going to insert some.
Now, owner's no longer
there as we hoped.
We just have name.
I'm going to try an
unauthenticated insert, which
will be go to sleep, my go-to.
And we'll see we have a 401,
which is what we expect.
So come back here.
This wouldn't have been true--
we wouldn't have to go back
through this if I hadn't have
reloaded the page.
So that's my bad.
So now we're authorized and
we can say go to sleep.
We can say wake up.
We can say what was it
about code janitor?
DAN HOLEVOET: Write
more unit tests.
Or write unit tests.
DANNY HERMES: Write
unit tests.
OK, great.
So we've got these and they're
associated with me.
So before we actually implement
the user base query,
I just want to actually
go to the Datastore.
So we have the Datastore Viewer
in the Admin console
for the local app.
And as we see, we have owner
is an actual user property
associated with the
signed-in user.
And I have these same names.
And we see it's a user
property rather
than a string property.
So great, back to the code.
So in the query, what we
actually want to do--
we simply need to filter
based on the owner.
So the way filters work in ndb--
again, as I said last
week, it's nontrivial ndb,
but it's pretty simple.
So to actually do this filter,
I'm just going to say
task.owner, which is the
property I want to filter on.
And I want to make sure that
task.owner is equal to the
signed-in user.
Let me make it a
little smaller.
And so what's actually happening
is I'm taking that
query and I'm filtering for
tasks specifically owned by
this particular user.
So let me refresh this one last
time, and I'm going to
have to sign-in again.
Sad face.
Feature Request.
Actually, I think it's
a security measure.
So I don't think it's ever
going to change.
OK, great.
So now if I go to--
DAN HOLEVOET: You didn't
wait long enough.
DANNY HERMES: I didn't
wait long enough?
DAN HOLEVOET: Yeah.
DANNY HERMES: So it happens
in a popup.
Apparently I left the page
before the popup
came back to the page.
Don't be impatient, Dan.
There we go.
Great.
So we have the items
I can limit.
You could just have one.
And I would--
well, in theory, you could use
Incognito, or other Chrome
profiles, or other browsers to
sign-in as a different user
and go through the same OAuth
flow with that user.
So that way, your queries
would not just
see all of the data.
But I don't really want to
expose more accounts, so I'm
going to wrap it up with that.
If you guys want to see
this code, we will--
where will we put it?
We will put it on the
internet somewhere.
DAN HOLEVOET: Yeah.
We could put it on GitHub, or
we could put it on your
example page.
DANNY HERMES: There we go.
We'll put it on the
downloads page for
Endpoints Proto Datastore.
And that's code.google.com/
p/endpoints-proto-datastore.
And at that page there's a bunch
of tabs across top, one
of which says Download.
So it'd just be
tasksapitalk.zip, or
something like this.
And we'll try to name the files
and various other pieces
such that it's obvious
what they are.
So from that, now that we're
wrapped up, we want to go to
the Moderator questions.
DAN HOLEVOET: Yes.
So I'm looking at the Moderator,
and it's empty
because all of this is so easy
and self-explanatory that no
one has questions.
DANNY HERMES: It's more
easy, more easy.
DAN HOLEVOET: Yeah.
Super easy.
DANNY HERMES: Cool.
So do we have anything else we
want to say, or do we just
want to call it?
DAN HOLEVOET: I think
we're good.
DANNY HERMES: All right.
Well, thanks everyone for coming
to this week's App
Engine GDL.
I hope you enjoyed it, and
we'll see you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]